Bud Light is still trying to salvage its
brand trying to trying to move on and
they have their latest attempt here and
every attempt is very funny because they
put out a new ad a new campaign and they
always put it I don't even know why they
bother putting the stuff on social media
anymore but they do and I'm glad that
they do it because then it's always a
lot of fun to read the comments and
they're just getting ripped apart for it
so they've teamed up with the Washington
Redskins who are still the Washington
Redskins as far as I'm concerned and
they've made this very fun commercial to
try to you know try to reset the brand
and here it is let's watch
[Music]
freedom
all right so there
it is uh All I'm gonna say is that first
of all if you're trying to be seen if
you're trying not to be seen as the gay
beer then that's not the way to do it
that's the opposite of what you want to
do uh you we we want to see football
players like
uh you know we want to see hard hits
tackling giving each other concussions
like that that's what if you really want
to reset the brand if you want any hope
of it then that's what it would be
uh instead you've got football players
okay that part's fine but they're all
just dancing
it really doesn't matter because it's
hopeless for Bud Light it just is their
brand is forever tarnished
um you know what it's like for that you
know what Bud Light is at this point I
think the best analogy is Bud Light
is basically like the kid in Middle
School who pees his pants in class and
and and that's what they are because
there's no coming back from it right the
kid who pees his pants in class is
always going to be that kid there's just
nothing you can't that you will always
be seen that way there's nothing you do
you can move schools or something and
change your name but that's the only
that's the only way and it's kind of
like that for Bud Light they're just the
kid who peed his pants and classes like
for any time anyone sees a Bud Light
they just can't help but laugh anymore
it's it's an automatic instinctive
reaction that people have because your
brand has been that tarnished
so what's the equivalent for Bud Light I
mean at least if you're in that position
you can change schools how does Bud
Light change schools as it were uh I
don't know they really can't
for most homeowners window replacements
it's not something that they've done
before and for many something that they
don't want to do but rather something
they have to do well if you've put off
replacing windows in your home because
it's too expensive I have great news you
can now get a free in-home window
consultation and free price quote from
Renewal by Anderson renewable Anderson
signature service is committed to giving
you the best customer experience
possible through the perfect combination
of the best people in the industry a
superior process and an exclusive
product right now Renewal by Anderson is
offering a free in-home or virtual
consultation on top quality affordable
windows or patio doors for zero dollars
down zero payments and zero interest for
a year text Walsh to 200 300 for your
free consultation to save 375 off every
window and 750 off every door these
savings won't last long so be sure to
check it out now by texting Walsh to 200
300 that's Walsh to 200 300 texting
privacy policy in terms of conditions
posted at textplan.us texting enrolls
for recurring automated text marketing
messages messaging data rates may apply
reply stop topped out go to
windowappointmentnow.com for full offer
details
I mean honestly just complete rename it
that's one thing they could do is rename
the beer exact same beer exact same
company give it a different name
honest to God that's their one hope
their one chance that's not gonna fool
me I'm not going to buy Bud Lights I
never would have bought them anyway but
I'm still not going to
uh but I think you know fast forward
another year or something I think that's
what we'll be looking at that's their
only hope is just give it a different
name
and uh
and then most people then maybe it won't
have that at least give give your
customers a chance like there are people
out there that for whatever reason enjoy
Bud Light and uh
and but they're not gonna
buy it and walk around holding it
because they know they're gonna
everyone's gonna make fun of them and so
there's just no they're not gonna do it
if you want to have any chance and you
have to allow
whoever your potential customers would
be to like purchase it and not be mocked
ruthlessly for it which probably means
you just need to change your name thanks
for checking out this video if you'd
like to listen to my full podcast on the
go you can check out the Matt wall show
on Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcasts